>> A JUDGE RELEASED THE FBI
SEARCH WARRANT ON TRUMP'S HOME.
FBI AGENTS TOOK 20 BOXES OF
ITEMS INCLUDED SOME MARKED AS
TOP-SECRET, A BATTLE GOING ON
WHETHER TRUMP DECLASSIFIED THE
DOCUMENTS FIRST.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE DON'T KNOW IF THE MATERIAL
WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE AFFIDAVIT
OR SIMPLY DISCOVERED IN THE
COURSE OF THE SEARCH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD THE ULTIMATE
DECLASSIFICATION AUTHORITY, BUT
THE AUTHORITY ENDED WHEN HE WAS
NO LONGER PRESIDENT.
>> I'D BE INTERESTED TO KNOW HOW
THEY ARE GOING TO PROVE IT'S
CLASSIFIED.
I'M SURE IT'S CLASSIFIED AT
ONE POINT BUT WE'VE NEVER
LITIGATED THIS BEFORE.
>> IT'S A QUESTION OF FACT HERE
ABOUT WHETHER PRESIDENT TRUMP
DECLASSIFIED IT OR NOT WHEN HE
STILL HAD THE POWER TO DO THAT.
>> I THINK THE BE IF EVERYBODY
HAS WITH THIS IS THAT THERE IS A
HIERARCHY, YOU'VE GOT
HILLARY CLINTON CASE AND
REMEMBER WHEN SHE SAID THERE IS
A C ON THE DOCUMENT.
SHE PLAYED STUPID.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
SHE HAD NO IDEA AND THEN TRUMP,
YOU GET A RAID.
>> Greg: WE SHOULD DO A SHOW
JUST CALLED WE DON'T KNOW AND
THAT WAY WE DON'T HAVE TO
KEEP -- THANK YOU FOR
TELEGRAPHING MY JOKE.
BUT WE HAVE TO START EVERYTHING
WITH LIKE WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE KNOW IS THAT THIS IS A
CASE OF WHATABOUTISM WORKS.
THE REAL-TIME COMMUNICATION AND
A SERVER IN A BATHROOM FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WHILE SHE WAS
COMMUNICATING WITH RUSSIA AND IT
ENDS UP ON ANTHONY'S LAPTOP
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
HE THEN USES TO SERVE THE WEB
FOR GOD KNOWS WHITE.
THAT'S LEAD BY.
AND YOU'VE GOT THINK ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN
, WHAT ABOUT THE STUFF LEFT
BEHIND IN
AFGHANISTAN?
WAS SOME OF THE CLASSIFIED?
WE LEFT IT WITH THE WORST ENEMY,
IT'S THE TALIBAN, JESSICA.
BUT THE FACT IS CONSIDER ALL THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE HELICOPTERS,
DOCUMENTS, COMPUTERS, MAYBE A
LOT OF IT WAS DESTROYED.
THERE ARE $7 BILLION WORTH OF
GEAR THAT WE KNOW WAS NOT
CONDUCTED WELL.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL WAS LOST
THEN.
IN THIS CASE, THE ONE ABOUTISM
IS THOROUGHLY VALID BECAUSE IT'S
THE CONTEXT THAT MAKES THIS SO
LAUGHABLE THAT 12 BOXES OF WHAT
IS RELATED TO SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT BE NUCLEAR?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IS IT A NOTE TO KIM JONG UN
SAYING I HAD A GREAT TIME?
>> Dan: WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT'S
WHAT ABOUTISM, I SAY YOU'RE
RIGHT.
THE STANDARD OF SO-CALLED
JUSTICE APPLIES TO ONE PARTY AND
NOT OTHERS, YOUR ARGUMENT IS
YES, THIS IS CORRECT?
NO, I'M NOT GOING TO EAT IT.
>> Dana: HILLARY CLINTON -- I
FORGOT THAT SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THE C MEN.
THE SANDY BERGER
ONE FOR ME, YOU'VE GOT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR GO TO
THE ARCHIVES AND DO SOME RESEARE
DOCUMENTS, AND ENDS UP WITH
PROBATION AND A FINE.
HIS HOUSE WAS NEVER RATED AND
MAY BE BECAUSE HE COOPERATED, I
DON'T KNOW.
THE OTHER THING -- LET ME MAKE
TWO OTHER POINTS.
LET'S SAY THERE IS A NUCLEAR
DOCUMENT.
LET ME MAKE TWO POINTS.
I HAVE FBI CLEARANCE, YOU
PROBABLY DID TOO.
YOU GO TO AN FBI BRIEFING, THERE
IS NOT A LOT OF PAPERWORK PASSED
OUT.
IF IT IS, IT'S COLLECTED AND
EVERYBODY TAKES IT BACK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU WOULD EVEN
HAVE AN FBI DOCUMENT TO PUT IN A
BOX.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
ALSO, IF IT'S SOMETHING TO DO
WITH NUCLEAR STUFF, WHY WOULD
THAT BE DECLASSIFIED?
IT'S A LETTER THAT SAYS, HEY,
GREAT TIME.
DON'T DO THAT LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
IF YOU DO IT, I'LL STOP CALLING
YOU THAT.
I UNDERSTAND CLASSIFYING THAT IS
FINE, BUT THAT SHE IS THE OTHER
THING, WE MAY NEVER KNOW.
LAST POINT I'LL MAKE IS THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORD CAME IN
AFTER WATERGATE.
THEN WE'VE GOT AN INVENTION
CALLED EMAIL AND THE INTERNET.
WE HAVE TENS OF THOUSAND
DOCUMENTS, AND NOW WE'VE GOT
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOCUMENTS.
IT'S ALL EMAILS, EVERYTHING
THING YOU EVER HE DID WHILE WERE
THERE ANOTHER TEXT MESSAGES THAT
ARE PRESIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS.
WE'VE NEVER LITIGATED THIS.
IF A PRESIDENT DECLASSIFIED
SOMETHING ON NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR
CAPABILITIES OR RESOURCES OR
LOCATIONS, HE COULD DO THAT.
BUT THERE IS A PROCESS THAT'S
NEVER BEEN TESTED IN COURT.
WHAT'S THE CIA DIRECTOR GOING TO
SAY?
TO THE ALLIES GET A SAY?
NONE OF IT HAS BEEN TESTED YET.
>> Dan: WHICH IS WHY WE
SHOULDN'T JUMP THE GUN.
IT'S DEFINITELY 100%
WHATABOUTISM.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
DON'T SEE IT THROUGH OUR EYES.
I CAN SEE YOUR PERSPECTIVE, I
GET IT.
HOW DO YOU NOT SEE THAT
HILLARY CLINTON LITERALLY DIDN'T
HAVE AN EMAIL WITH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, WAS
UNCOMFORTABLE UNQUESTIONABLY
EMAILING.
WHEN YOU SEE HOW WE ARE ANNOYED
THAT THIS IS NOW A MAJOR DEAL
WHERE THEY HAVE A RAID?
YOU DON'T GET THAT?
>> I GET IT, I'VE SPENT PLENTY
OF TIME WITH PEOPLE WHO SHARE
YOUR WORLDVIEW AND I'M PRETTY ST
THIS POINT AND I'M GOOD AT
SAYING IT'S NOT ONE TO BE LIKE
THIS, IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE
THIS.
THAT'S IMPORTANT AND WE SHOULD
SPEND MORE TIME TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO DON'T SHARE OUR OWN
WORLDVIEW.
THAT I MISS THE POINT OF
AMERICAN HISTORY WHERE
HILLARY CLINTON WAS PRESENT IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AFTER SHE HAD SENT CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON A SERVER AND WENT
ON A BEAUTIFUL FOUR YEAR TERM
AND WHATEVER ELSE.
SHE LOST THE ELECTION BECAUSE OF
AN FBI INVESTIGATION 11 DAYS
BEFORE A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
JIM COMEY HEAD OF THE FBI CAME
OUT AND SAID THAT THEY HAD
REOPENED A YEAR-LONG
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THERE'S
NEW INFORMATION THAT ENDED UP
BEING A DOG.
THEN HE HAS TO COME
OUT AND SAY THAT.
AND THEN HE HAD TO EAT YOU KNOW
WHAT FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS
BECAUSE EVERYBODY HATES HIM
BECAUSE HE DID THAT BECAUSE HE
VIOLATED PROTOCOL COMING OUT AND
COMMENTING ON AN ONGOING FBI
INVESTIGATION, WHICH BY THE WAY
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, TRUMP
APPOINTEE AND MERRICK GARLAND
BOTH DID NOT DO UNTIL THEY ARE
HANDED BY TRUMP.
HILLARY CLINTON HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATED BY THE FBI BY THE
SENATE REPUBLICAN RUN SENATE
COMMITTEE WHO BOTH FOUND THAT
HER SERVER WAS NEVER HACKED BY A
FOREIGN ENTITY.
>> Dan: I ACTUALLY HAVE A
SWORD.
BEFORE I HAVE A SORE LIKE EVERY
SENATE REPUBLICAN
WHO WOULD HAVE LOVED THEN WHY
DID SENATE REPUBLICANS WHO HAD
SAY ON THE LIST OF THINGS THAT
THEY HATE HAVE HILLARY CLINTON
LIKE WAY UP HIGH.
THEY'VE SET IT OUT LOUD IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY FOUND.
I GET IT AND WHEN THAT HAPPENED,
I SAID SHE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN DOING THINGS BY THE
BOOK ON THIS, BUT THEY ARE NOT
COMPARABLE AND FOR YOU TO ACT
LIKE SHE WON ANY OF THIS, SHE
LOST THE BIGGEST ELECTION THERE
IS.
>> Dan: I DON'T REMEMBER THE
SEARCH WARRANT ON HILLARY'S
HOUSE.
AND >> Jessica: MAY BE BECAUSE
SHE DIDN'T REFUSE TO COMPLY?
>> Dagen: THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TREATED HILLARY CLINTON
WITH NOT JUST KID LOVE, THEY
CALLED -- CODDLED HER LIKE A
BABY.
HER ANSWERS WERE SO RIDICULOUS,
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN CHARGED
WITH MAKING FALSE STATEMENTS.
A REMINDER, MARTHA STEWART WENT
TO PRISON FOR FIVE MONTHS FOR
DOING THAT VERY THING.
THERE'S ONLY ONE THING THAT
MATTERS IN THIS, WHAT YOU GOT?
GIVE IT TO ME.
IT BETTER BE BIG, SUPERSIZED,
LIKE JUPITER SIZED INFORMATION
FOR YOU TO CRUSH A STANDARD THAT
STOOD IN THIS COUNTRY FOR MORE
THAN TWO CENTURIES, MORE THAN
230.
JESS, I UNDERSTAND THAT THE LEFT
AND DEMOCRATS DON'T LIKE TRUMP,
BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
AREN'T MORE UPSET ABOUT AN FBI
RUN BY CHRIS WRAY AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT RUN BY
MERRICK GARLAND THAT DEFRAUDED
AND DECEIVED ALL AMERICAN PEOPLE
WITH THE RUSSIA COLLUSION FRAUD,
THE DOSSIER, LYING REPEATEDLY TO
SPY ON AN AMERICAN CITIZEN WHEN
THE FISA COURT ITSELF CALLED OUT
THE FBI.
THAT INSPECTOR GENERAL HOROWITZ
AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CALLED
OUT THE FBIS MALFEASANCE.
PUT UP OR SHUT UP, IF YOU FOUND
SOMETHING, CHARGE THE PRESIDENT.
HE COULD PULL A JIM COMEY, HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO
IT, BUT TECHNICALLY HE'S GOT THE
POWER TO DO IT.
WHEN THE EVIDENCE SEIZED REMAIN
SEALED UNTIL IT'S INTRODUCED AS
PART OF A CRIMINAL PROCEEDING,
BUT HE CAN STEP UP AND SAY THIS
IS WHAT WE'VE GOT.
THIS IS WHAT WE'VE GOT ON
TRUMP -- THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS
ON ALL OF THIS AND THEY WON'T DO
IT BECAUSE AGAIN, THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR JANUARY 6TH.
>> Dan: LET ME SAY IN CLOSING,
HILLARY DIDN'T COMPLY WHEN THEY
SMASHED BLACKBERRIES WITH
HAMMERS.
I WANT TO PUT THAT IN THERE.
HAMMERS, THEY SMASH THEM WITH
HAMMERS, THAT'S NOT COMPLYING.
UP NEXT, THE FBI